[Music]
on this Friday night making things right
ahead of the national day of Truth and
Reconciliation a stolen sacred Monument
returns to its rightful place in BC it
will resonate through all of the First
Nations a First Nations celebrations for
a homecoming nearly a century in the
making
demands for change on the path of
reconciliation your granddaughter your
daughter was sitting in a landfill what
would you do what indigenous communities
say the country is still lagging behind
on
a billion dollars off defense what
Canada's top Soldier is warning as
Ottawa aims to cut down military
spending and remembering an American
political Trailblazer the Legacy that
U.S senator Dianne Feinstein leaves
behind after serving to the very end
global national with para Nasser
reporting Tonight Eric Sorensen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a long-awaited homecoming
in Northwestern BC the niska first
nation is celebrating the return of a
memorial totem pole nearly a century
after it was taken without permission
indigenous communities have long carved
their memories laws and spiritual
beliefs into sacred totem poles once
outlawed in Canada many were destroyed
or taken by Traders and sold around the
world a community welcoming ceremony was
held for the sacred structure after its
arrival home from Europe the journey was
long and complex the 11 meter red cedar
totem pole was taken 94 years ago and
sold to the national museum of Scotland
Global's nitu garcha is in niska nation
for the emotional homecoming Tonight
nitu Eric especially for survivors who
have endured the horrors of colonization
for Generations there are many layers of
meaning to this moment the niska museum
behind me houses hundreds of stolen
artifacts returned after the nation
signed the first modern treaty in BC
more than 20 years ago and while there
are still several sacred items missing
this totem pole was high on the list
this is a momentous occasion for niska
nation and Beyond
it marks the beginning of true
reconciliation when it comes to bringing
our ancestors home for day school
survivor president Eva Clayton the
long-awaited return of a sacred totem
pole to the lands on which it was carved
from red cedar is as exciting as it is
emotional for me it's validating what
had happened and the return of this poll
is incredible we hope that it is also
inspiring and giving Colonial
institutions just further support in
terms of doing the right thing Dr Amy
parent first found out it was in
Scotland four years ago she says her
ancestral Grandmother Had the 11 meter
Memorial pole carved in honor of a
warrior who was destined to become Chief
before being killed protecting his
Nation it's been nearly 100 years since
the totem pole was stolen from us by
Colonial ethnographer Marius Barbeau my
heart is so happy to be here with you
honoring the nation's matrilineal
Society they call it a rematriation
considered to have a living Spirit the
totem pole is like a relative finally
returning home
Dr Parent was among the delegation to
Scotland last year who after three
months of negotiations successfully
secured the return the poll traveled on
a Canadian military strategic airlift
aircraft from Scotland to Terrace BC and
then transported by road to the niska
museum in the community of lackles up
some 1 000 people are participating in a
ceremony and feast tonight including
community members Federal and provincial
politicians and representatives from the
Museum of Scotland as they Mark the
completion of a journey nearly a century
in the making Eric thanks Nation
later a report card on reconciliation in
Canada we'll look at the path forward on
this weekend of reflection and healing
but first Canada's top Soldier is
warning of a bumpy road ahead for the
armed forces the federal government is
looking to slash almost one billion
dollars from the Department of National
Defense the move is part of a wider
liberal campaign to find Savings in
federal spending but as Mackenzie gray
reports critics say right now it sends
the wrong message
it's a stark warning from Canada's top
Soldier there's no way that you can take
almost a billion dollars out of the
defense budget and not have an impact
that billion dollar cut to defense
spending demanded by the federal
government as a part of a larger bid to
find 15 billion in savings but selling
that to Frontline soldiers a difficult
task you know our people see the the
degrading declining security situation
around the world and so trying to
explain this to them is very difficult
an explanation the opposition isn't
buying these liberals waste money on
just about everything except our
military why does the Prime Minister
only cut spending when it hurts our
troops and we are committed to the
significant and strategic long-term
Investments that will ensure that calf
continues to function as an agile combat
ready for us those long-term Investments
promised by Canada this summer
reinforcing a pledge to Nato to increase
defense spending to two percent of GDP
but right now Canada Falls well short of
that Mark spending only 1.3 set to get
to that natal promise the feds would
need to spend an additional 18 billion
annually not only are you a laggard
within your NATO alliance but you're
actually seeing that there are very few
places to further cut the minister
overseeing the cuts treasury board
president Anita Anand whose previous
role is defense minister saw a fight for
more military spending one of the most
rewarding parts of my job is to work
hard for the Canadian Armed Forces in
terms of ensuring that they have the
capabilities the capacities the
resources that they need the cuts spread
over five years and represent only 0.7
percent of the total Armed Forces annual
budget but it's reducing spending as
threats from Russia and China are only
growing I don't think this is a helpful
message I think they should have made an
exception to the rule that they ask all
departments to affect cuts and excluded
defense and explain why the the move is
unlikely to help with the enormous
recruiting and retention issues facing
the military right now with an estimated
10 000 vacancies across the entire Armed
Forces Eric
Mac there's also news coming out of CFB
Trenton today a Canadian Forces Colonel
has been permanently removed from his
position as a commander at the base what
can you tell us about this
well Eric it's a bizarre story colonel
leafdahl was the commander of Canada's
largest Air Force Base but now he's
facing numerous Firearms charges after
he allegedly used a rifle and a revolver
to shoot at protected Wildlife from a
boat near Belleville Ontario back in
August now the Ontario provincial police
showed up and that's when doll allegedly
dumped both guns into the water but OPP
dive teams were able to recover the
weapons and that's left Dahl losing one
of the top jobs in the Air Force Eric
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
an associate of the BC sick leader shot
and killed in the city of Surrey says he
was warned by police about threats to
his life about two months after Hardeep
Singh Niger was murdered gurmeet Singh
tour says he received a duty to warn
document from law enforcement Toria isri
reports
before his murder Canadian authorities
told hardeep's signature his life was in
danger and it appears he was not alone
friend and fellow sick activist gurmeet
singhtur says Suri RCMP and the
integrated National Security enforcement
team or inset paid him a visit August
24th in interview through a translator
tour says on the night of August 24th
officers knocked on his door and handed
him this document titled duty to warn
the police have determined by way of one
or more investigative avenues that your
life may be in Peril at this time we are
unable to provide you specific details
of the threat
the u.s-based group six for justice
which advocates for a separate state
from India shared the document Global
News has verified it and found its
consistent with forms bcrcmp fill out
when the RCMP sends out these kinds of
warnings it's not done just because they
think there's some sort of vague threat
it's often done because there's credible
threats information
tour says he's going public to protect
himself because he's afraid he could end
up like Niger Niger had his suspicions
and shared them in a radio interview
back in May
[Music]
um
India has the ability to do what he said
the Indian government calls the
allegations absurd and labeled Niger a
terrorist
good afternoon everyone the Indian
minister of external Affairs traveled to
the United States this week and met with
the U.S Secretary of State and U.S
national security adviser they obviously
shared
you know U.S views and
assessments on this whole situation
while Washington finds itself in the
middle of the Diplomatic dispute between
Ottawa and New Delhi sick Canadians find
themselves increasingly worried about
their safety and the safety of family
abroad teria is Reit Global News Ottawa
hundreds of Air Canada Pilots picketed
at Toronto's Pearson Airport as labor
talks between their Union and the
country's biggest carrier drag on the
airline pilots Association and Air
Canada both say the so-called
informational picket did not affect
flight schedules the union which
represents some five thousand Pilots is
calling for higher salaries and better
scheduling to narrow the Gap with their
American counterparts
in the U.S nearly 7 000 Auto Workers
walked off the job today joining more
than eighteen thousand others at
America's big three a Ford plant in
Illinois and a General Motors plant in
Michigan were the targets of the latest
job action
the possibility of a U.S government
shutdown is looming both chambers of
Congress continue to butt heads over
passing a short-term spending bill that
would keep the government open for
another 30 days but with more on the
possible shutdown and what it would mean
let's go live to Brittany Rosen who
joins us from Capitol Hill Brittany
Eric time is running out and a
government shutdown is looking quite
inevitable at this point right now it's
scheduled for Sunday at 1201 am
the bill is not passed with a vote of
198 years and 232 Nays a last minute
long shot bid to pass a stopgap bill to
keep the government open did not pass in
the House of Representatives Friday one
thing if I hope you realize about me is
I never give up the bill put forward by
Republican house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
was almost destined to fail with a lack
of support from his own party and an
unwillingness from a handful of
hard-line Republicans to back the
legislation under any circumstances the
only way out of a shutdown is
bipartisanship with a bill unable to get
through
that it the pop
per lawmakers to work together you need
to take the American workforce out of
the political theater a shutdown would
mean millions of workers would be
furloughed those in the military and
Transportation safety Authority would be
forced to work without pay a number of
Washington museums national landmarks
and all national parks would close but
the ripple effect would be much larger
travel delays and disruptions to
Medicare Social Security and food
assistance programs thank you impacting
Americans who depend on those Services
the most why aren't they doing their
jobs we're paying them to do it there
have been 14 government shutdowns since
1980. the longest was in 2018 lasting 34
days during the Trump presidency this
shutdown is very different from 2018 in
a couple of ways one is that large parts
of the government were not shut down
during the 2018 shutdown
now what's notable here is that members
of Congress will still receive their
paychecks and so we can expect lawmakers
here on Capitol Hill to be working
throughout the weekend trying to come up
with a solution but at this point Eric
there is no clear path forward
knee Rosen in Washington thank you
the unsold murder of a rap icon back in
the spotlight
coming up a new suspect arrested nearly
30 years after Tupac Shakur was gunned
down
there's a major development in one of
America's most notorious cold cases a
suspect has been arrested and charged
with the 1996 murder of rapper Tupac
Shakur
27 years
for 27 years the family of Tupac Shakur
has been waiting for justice
we are here today to announce the arrest
of 60 year old Dwayne Keith Davis aka
keefy D for the murder of Tupac Shakur
Tupac was gunned down as he left a
boxing match on the Las Vegas Strip in
1996. police believe Davis was inside
the car involved in the drive-by
shooting and when they searched his home
in July they say they found
corroborating evidence he's the only one
facing charges the other three men
inside the suspect vehicle are now dead
and Pakistan dozens are dead after
suicide bombers attacked mosques in two
provinces in the country's Southwest a
powerful bomb exploded as people were
gathering to celebrate the birthday of
the Prophet Muhammad more than 50 people
were killed later at least five people
died in explosions at a mosque west of
Islamabad no one has claimed
responsibility for the attacks Pakistan
is facing a dramatic Resurgence in
violent attacks against its security
officials and civilians
in the UK the crash of a school bus has
claimed the life of a 14 year old girl
and the bus driver the bus overturned on
a highway this morning as it was taking
students to school two children are in
hospital in Liverpool with serious
injuries eight others were taken to
surrounding hospitals investigators are
trying to establish what caused the bus
to flip on its side
[Music]
ahead remembering a Trailblazer for
women in politics what set U.S senator
Dianne Feinstein apart
[Music]
Dianne Feinstein the longest serving
woman in the U.S Senate has passed away
at the age of 90. Representative Nancy
Pelosi spoke today on the house floor to
remember her colleague and honor her
longtime friend
to please rise for a moment of silence
in remembrance of the late honorable
Senator Dianne Feinstein
senator from California Dianne Feinstein
only ran to be a U.S senator after
watching the Senate confirmation
hearings of Clarence Thomas that grilled
not the Supreme Court nominee but the
woman who accused him of sexual
harassment what did I see but an
all-male Senate Judiciary Committee
grilling Anita Hill and it was not nice
Feinstein blazed a trail for women in
politics but her career was launched
amid tragedy when San Francisco mayor
George Moscone and supervisor Harvey
Milk were assassinated at City Hall in
1978 it was supervisor Feinstein who
stepped forward both Mayor Moscone
supervisor Harvey Milk
have been shot
she was elected mayor outspoken and fast
rising in Democratic Party politics she
was on Walter mondale's shortlist for
vice presidential running mate in 1984.
she was elected California's first woman
senator in 1992 was put on the Judiciary
Committee by Senator Joe Biden and
spearheaded a ban on assault weapons she
went out and did something that was a
product of an incredible amount of work
after 9 11 as chair of Senate
intelligence she led the review of the
cia's controversial waterboarding of
prisoners she would take on any Force
any special interest any opponent with
Ruth with Relentless Integrity Feinstein
was Fearless yet sought consensus
something increasingly rare in politics
today this sounds like old-fashioned
politics which I still adhere to she was
always looking for where that Common
Ground could be found and inhabited with
health and memory failing Feinstein
stayed on in the Senate during difficult
final months but she is being remembered
for all she accomplished she was a path
breaker at a time when it was even
harder for women to be in leadership
roles even Republicans are honoring her
a testament to a political Pioneer an
extraordinary Senator she was a
Trailblazer for women
[Music]
athletes with the Lethbridge kodiaks
unveiled their new indigenous jerseys
today the uniforms are just one way
Canadians are commemorating the national
day for Truth and Reconciliation
tomorrow more on the path to
reconciliation next
[Music]
this temporary heart Garden has been
planted at the University of Manitoba to
commemorate the national day for Truth
and Reconciliation each of the 310
Hearts represents the memory of a child
lost to the residential school system
while honoring survivors
tomorrow marks the national day for
Truth and Reconciliation but
commemorations are taking place all
weekend it's a time to reflect on this
country's history and relationship with
indigenous people residential school
survivors say just as important as a
truthful look back is forging The Way
Forward Melissa Ridgid reports
residential school survivor Jennifer
Wood has waited a long time to feel like
this Canada has a different lens that
they're looking through in terms of
reconciliation they're looking at our
survivors in our Legacy in a different
way her mother and five siblings went to
residential school too and for most of
their lives carried those scars Alone
part of a dark history unknown to many
Canadians until recent years I believe
that people are bringing down their
walls of what they thought of survivors
I think now they have a greater
appreciation for survivors she feels
Canadians for the most part take
reconciliation seriously
like newcomer Mark Turner I moved here
back in 2014 so as a non-indigenous like
settler
and a steward of a business that's on
treaty one territory
I think it's important for me
to like learn more and also educate the
people in my life and like my staff as
well September 30th is a federal stat
holiday but only four provinces and both
territories recognize it with a day off
Manitoba is not one of them
for the past two years Turner has closed
his restaurant anyway this year he's
doing it again on what's usually his
busiest day of the week I think it's
important to close down to kind of like
raise awareness and like honor the
survivors of
um the residential schools but some say
the most obvious Act of reconciliation
that could be happening isn't
searching a Winnipeg landfill for the
remains of at least three murdered
indigenous women
Manitoba Premier Heather Stephenson
refused citing safety and cost I have to
protect all manitobans throughout this
including those that would be asked to
go into those landfills it sparked
Nationwide protests search that landfill
and do it now
your granddaughter your daughter was
sitting in a landfill and nobody wanted
what you do
we'd be crying and fighting and that's
what we're doing manitobans go to the
poll Tuesday the NDP have said if they
win the landfill search will happen
while conservatives stand by their
decision to not search families and
Advocates hope next September 30th we'll
see reconciliation in action at the
landfill Melissa Ridge in Global News
Winnipeg
there is support for survivors a 24-hour
crisis line for anyone experiencing pain
or distress as a result of their
residential school experience you can
call toll free and speak in confidence
at 1-800-721-0066
and that's global national for this
Friday I'm Eric Sorensen tonight's your
Canada is a collection of stamps to
commemorate the national day for Truth
and Reconciliation the Canada post
stamps feature archival images of four
residential schools they were designed
in collaboration with the survivor's
circle of the national Center For Truth
and Reconciliation
thanks for watching
[Music]